parce que nos vies se transforme
perpétuellement nous avons le devoir de
recycler tous ces matériaux yprema votre
partenaire pour un développement durable
je t'écris ces quelques lignes pour te
dire que oui je suis prêt à faire un
petit bout de chemin avec toi ps quand
je prends deux bouts de chemin je veux
dire départ de chez moi arriver au
boulot puis retour mais aussi possible
tous les jours
merci à toi le covoiturage c'est
convivial économique et écologique
avec le covoiturage saint quentin en
yvelines vous propose une nouvelle façon
de vous déplacer
les inscriptions et les infos sur
www.covoiturage.fr lotir et est-ce qu y
point fr
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro d' équilibre le magazine de
l'environnement et du développement
durable
dans ce numéro nous parlerons des
écogestes ses petites habitudes du
quotidien une coûte pas forcément
beaucoup des formes qui peuvent avoir
beaucoup d'impact pour la planète mais
aussi pour votre portefeuille
alors il s'agit de notre consommation
électrique de nos habitudes alimentaires
ou encore de produits ménagers
tout d'abord nous avons rendez vous avec
sébastien mais les conseillers info
énergie de l' agence locale de l'énergie
et du climat pour décrypter notre
facture notre consommation d'électricité
sébastien beslay bonjour bonjour merci
de nous recevoir
alors depuis le début de l'année la loi
nous a obligés à changer nos ampoules à
incandescence pour les ampoules basse
consommation
quel impact ça peut avoir d'abord une
réduction de la facture une plus grande
efficacité lumineuse
parce qu'en fait ces ampoules elles ont
un rendement de 5%
c'est à dire que seulement 5 % de
l'énergie consommée par ces ampoules va
être donné en lumière donc c'est 95%
perte c'est énorme avec des ampoules
telle qu'on sait qu'on trouve maintenant
halogènes ou lampes basse consommation
des death et des rendements
les rapports sont inversés en fait si
vous voulez donc de meilleurs rendements
des consommations du cou qui baissent
aussi quel est le plus gros poste de
consommation à la maison alors ça reste
le chauffage en terme d'électricité on a
un poste qui est de plus en plus
prédominance électricité spécifique qui
va pouvoir représenter presque 20% de la
consommation
on a de plus en plus d'équipements de
plus en plus de téléviseurs qui sont de
plus en plus grands consomment de plus
en plus des smartphones des tablettes
tout un tas d'équipements qui mine de
rien consomme petit à petit ouais
comment on peut faire pour réduire ce
plus gros poste là en tout cas alors
déjà faire attention c'est d'aimer
postes qui sont branchés constamment
donc on va faire en sorte de
qu'ils soient bien éteint à ce qu'ils
consomment pas quand on les utilise pas
donc pour ça on a la technique bien
connue des multiprises avec interrupteur
voilà que je peux représenter encore
mais qu'on connaît bien maintenant on a
aussi tous les petits appareils de
programmation j'en ai pris au hasard
voilà le minuteur tout simple qui coûte
pas grand chose mais qui permet alors
comment ils utilisent et ben c'est pas
difficile en règle leur par rapport à la
montre et puis vous avez des petits cran
voilà ça c'est un mécanique modèle très
simple les des petits cran quand on
baisse les petits cran ça va consommer
quand ils sont montés sa coupe
donc ça peut être très pratique pour des
appareils qui ont fonctionné que la
journée par exemple on va faire
attention aux veilles toutes ces petites
lumières signifie petite consommation on
va leur faire la guerre et veiller un
chasseur veille ce qu'on appelle chasse
au gaspillage qui peut représenter entre
10 et 20% d'économie mine de rien sur la
facture totale d'électricité
c'est énorme c'est énorme l'ensemble des
veilles en france pour présenter la
fermeture de quelques réacteurs
nucléaires donc ça donne un ordre d'idée
par rapport à notre le potentiel de
consommation et le potentiel d'économies
qu'il ya derrière ces petites veille
merci beaucoup pour ses précieux
conseils
maintenant je vous propose de découvrir
une initiative étonnante il plante à
l'arrivée du printemps des fruits et des
légumes
mais pour les partager alors julie rocha
soares est parti à la rencontre de ces
jardiniers citoyens du top
de la ciboulette du romarin et du
laurier sauce du jardin des légumes et
herbes aromatiques à disposition et
gratuit de quoi étonner les passants car
les jardinières de mélissa d'un village
d'el hank où sont disposées côté rue
sous l'affichette nourriture à partager
selon le concept d incroyables
comestibles avec les incroyables comme
estime c'est l'idée qu'on peut partager
simplement ce qu'on a en abondance bain
plutôt que de laisser mourir de le jeter
moi je trouve que ça nous redonne un
petit peu de pouvoir à nous en tant
qu'individu de se dire 20 peut planter
des choses peut les manger et et mieux
je peux en proposer aux autres et
partager des productions locales qui
proviennent de son propre potager ou des
jardins pédagogiques environnants
le phénomène philanthropique né en
angleterre il ya cinq ans pour répondre
à la crise devenue mondiale il prend
doucement racines depuis un mois à saint
quentin en yvelines un projet citoyen
solidaire soutenu par l'association
saint quentin en yvelines en transition
et se tuent des invités déplaçant les
voisins les personnes qui veulent pas du
tout va les écoliers tout le monde
debout tu es et en fait ça ça ouvre une
conversation ce qu'est ce que cette
alimentation locale
ce n'est pas pour remplacer de mes
recherches de cas c'est vraiment de
faire conversation qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire nous qu'est-ce qu'on peut manger
de l'ocam ans qu'est ce qui pousse ici
en saison
cette saison ligny montana fait de
nombreux amis pour en faire profiter
tout son entourage et les oignons des
fleurs comestibles
il ya des inquiétudes parce que ça peut
éloigner les insectes nuisibles
tout différend sur deux salles des
cibles est en cours les feuilles
comestibles
ça c'est un premier que j'ai planté avec
une graine parce que sa famille en plus
de ces initiatives ambitieuses de
particuliers des commune yvelinoise
devrait mettre en place prochainement
des bacs en ville pour créer des
potagers partager estampillé incroyable
comestibles à suivre donc
nous restons dans le jardinage avec le
potager de cocagne cette association
solidaire propose des fruits et légumes
bio toute l'année venez je vais vous
montrer et on retrouve alain gérard vous
êtes le directeur de l'association
bonjour bonjour alors qu'est ce qu'on
trouve dans votre jardin ton jardin de
cocagne
on retrouve des légumes comme vous voyez
là des blagues des épinards des salades
mais également quelques fruits des
fraises des framboises des cassis tout
au long de l'année
alors ici on respecte les normes de
l'agriculture biologique
qu'est ce que ça veut dire biologique
c'est dans le respect de l'environnement
de tout ce qui est en grève on fait très
attention à préserver l'environnement de
la culture en général on est
certification bio qui ne se fait qu'au
bout de deux ans et on l'a eu il ya
maintenant au mois de mars 2012 c'est
tout récent et puis c'est aussi un
jardin qui a la particularité d'être
solidaire qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça
solidaires parce qu on accompagne des
personnes qui sont très éloignées
d'emploi pour le retrouver des repères
et les orienter vers un travail durable
de préférence bien entendu et recréer
une dynamique à ces personnes là c'est
notre objectif premier le deuxième
objectif c'est de faire des cultures
biologiques de légumes au produit mais
on voit également c'est le propre des
jardins de cocagne vous employez combien
de personnes lycée on emploie 18
salariés en insertion nos jardiniers
qu'on accompagne et il y a cinq
permanences il ya des personnes qui
encadrent et qu'ils vont faire tout le
côté social et professionnel également
alors vous l'avez dit c'est aussi ouvert
au public comment ça fonctionne combien
comment on vient acheter ses produits
alors pour être acheteur dans ta jambe
cocagne il faut être d'abord adhérents
c'est dire qu'on paie une cotisation à
l'année qui permet d'avoir accès à un
panier hebdomadaire de légumes et les
fruits et également à une boutique
cirque une personne peut acheter deux
fois par semaine ces légumes comme elle
le désire le mardi soir et vendredi
soirs de 16 heures à 19 heures également
si elle veut elle peut avoir un panier
toutes les semaines qu'elle vient
chercher ici
directement quitterait du lien et des
légumes vous avez combien d'adhérents
on a cent soixante dix adhérents
aujourd'hui sachant qu'au démarrage des
barrettes 40 adhérents seulement donc on
est en pleine progression et on espère
encore se développer
le fait d'acheter panier bas permet
d'accompagner les personnes les
formations auprès de nos jardiniers
alors justement combien vous vendez de
fruits et légumes par semaine par mois
alors on vend sans soins dix paniers par
semaine un des adhérents consommateurs
le prix du panier ses 17 euros par
semaine qui correspond à un panier pour
quatre personnes
de cinq à sept fruits et légumes vous
proposer ainsi une nouvelle activité
s'appelle des mains dans la terre est ce
que vous pouvez nous en parler
or les mains dans la terre c'est un
jardin pédagogique qui est porté par
l'association sky en transition qui est
hébergé par jean de cocagne est ce qui
permet à des personnes d'apprendre
l'agriculture biologique c'est des cours
sur différentes thématiques liées aux
jardins au maraîchage également aux
fleurs donc ça c'est toute l'année c'est
toute l'année c'est des thèmes qui sont
faits sur le site internet les gens
peuvent s'inscrire sur le site et janis
il généralement le week-end c'est
l'activité dominicale pour apprendre
comment faire des plantations
biologiques comment gérer la terre
comment faire son compost voit plein de
choses naturelles est bonne pour la
nature est bonne pour la santé
merci beaucoup rendez vous est donné
donc cursif moi de mon côté je vous
propose maintenant une activité
d'intérieur de la cuisine du ménage
un peu des deux en fait puisque vous
allez découvrir comment on peut faire
soi même des produits ménagers
sans être un grand chimiste reportage
deux cuillérées de bicarbonate de soude
quelques centilitres de vinaigre blanc
trois gouttes d'huile essentielle ces
femmes ne concocte pas leur prochain
repas
mais des produits d'entretien ménager le
tout à base d'ingrédients naturels
acheter bio oui tu vois là non pour oser
l'année hop c'est une première avec la
bonne note de ce que je connais
j'utilisais chez moi mais je mélangeais
pas avec deux produits utilisés nature
comme ça je connaissais pas un produit
alors j'allais kosiner marie noëlle le
breton est déjà une adepte de cette
drôle de cuisine elle est venue trouver
de nouveaux conseils car elle en est
convaincu ces produits n'ont que des
avantages
c'est efficace et puis oui mais enfin
toute façon moi c'est très bien pour mon
porte monnaie
et puis au moins c'est pas toxique pour
la maison c'est naturel c'est bon
objectifs de l'atelier informer sur les
risques des produits toxiques et surtout
permettre les changes des recettes de
grand-mère de chacun c'est un atelier en
fait des échanges de savoirs donc on
donne des informations on est preneur
aussi d'informations que les personnes
ont également leur savoir faire à la
maison
résultat de l'opération un produit tout
usage un liquide vaisselle est
certainement un coup de balai dans les
placards des produits ménagers ainsi
s'achève ce numéro d' équilibre qui vous
aura donné j'espère des astuces pour
prendre de nouvelles habitudes avant de
nous quitter quelques dates à noter dans
vos agendas
l'association sky en transition et le
jardin de cocagne vous propose en
atelier les mains dans la terre le 4 mai
à 10h30 et le 5 mai à 14 heures vous
pourrez découvrir les plantes sauvages
comestibles médicinales ou encore
réaliser un potager mandala puis le 27
avril les jardins familiaux de
guyancourt vous proposent leur troc de
plantes de 14 heures à 16 heures
toujours le 27 avril vous pourrez
découvrir les serres municipales
d'elancourt à l'occasion de leurs portes
ouvertes
vous pourrez profiter de conseils de
jardiniers et même vous fournir en terro
moi je vous donne rendez vous le 17 mai
pour un prochain nouveau numéro d'
équilibre d'ici là bon vent et à la
prochaine